one more time on this episode we talk
about contradictions text on top of
Instagram photos and the female version
of me
[Music]
[Music]
this is
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 105 of the ask gary vee
show a very special weekend edition of
the askgaryvee show I hope you're
enjoying your weekend
I hope this starts it off right with the
right amount of energy and India by the
way before we go to India let's get into
the show you think I'll have this book
I'm massively upset with you
India let's get into the show Q Studios
Inc asks Gary Vee as a successful solo
entrepreneur do I have to grow my
business bigger than I can handle alone
Q Studios Inc that's a great question I
think the answer to that question is
completely predicated on what you want
in life I mean you've set up the
question by saying you're a successful
solo entrepreneur are you making the
monies and are you fulfilled enough to
keep it at a one-woman one-man show I
mean to me I I can't answer that for you
you know I just had an interesting
conversation with AJ you know our our
professional ambitions are in a
different place everyone's are you know
if you want to build a bigger business
you need to build it outside of one
person you know you can only be so big
but maybe what you're getting and what
you've got and how it goes appeals to
you I find a lot of people not being
able to be good managers they love to
micromanage their romantic and obsessive
about what they do they don't allow
other people to come into their
ecosystem and they struggle with the
growth curve and they get just a little
exponential growth you know they go from
making seventy three thousand dollars a
year to 113 but it comes with a lot of
pain because they don't like it you know
they're there they're there their
intraverted their solo acts they're
there you know flawed and building out a
big business but incredibly good and
happy at doing their things so it's not
about you know making more there's a
there's really a fine line of like
making more money but giving up too much
of the your happiness for that bigger
money amounts and then and then there's
probably a place where that money's
justifies what you want but to me doing
what you love and doing
the way you love to do it is really
really really important I happen to be
lucky that that also creates wealth and
and big dollars but for the people that
it doesn't they need to reconcile and
look what I don't get is a lot of other
things which is you know kind of the
relaxation or the lack of pressure that
comes along with some of the smaller
plays but I can't answer this question
for you you need to know yourself this
goes back to all the self-awareness
stuff that I'm trying to put out this
goes back to yesterday's video about you
know or a couple days ago video of you
know a day in the life for a lot of
people critique you know my work-life
balance my family time this that and the
reason that video ends with you know
that's me now do you
that's a perfect way I actually do you
rock link up there give me like a me 13
seconds of the day in the life video
right now I'm back and so you know I
think I'm I think it's on you
Adam asks you say one play to your
strengths - don't worry about small
details what if my strengths is
attention to detail
Adam couple things and this is for the
entire vaynernation
so many of the things that I say are
contradictions I like pulling from both
directions that's where I think the
strength comes in I really do think of
life business as a bridge if you pull
equally very hard ego humility right you
know I don't care what anybody thinks
about me I care about what everybody
thinks about me right you know big big
big picture clouds but I'm a
practitioner I know more about all the
details of social than you details dirt
and so I love pulling from opposite
directions so if I'm giving advice and
you're listening to 105 composite shows
and things are coming from different
angles that are contradictions this is
where you have to go within yourself and
not listen to a guru because I'm not one
nor is anyone else this is on you to
figure out that and so if your strengths
are you know to me in that and to me and
that one you bet on your I mean look I
can answer these in detail I will this
time I would bet on the strength school
your detail-oriented you need to
recognize two things if your skill set
is detail-oriented two things are gonna
happen one if you're the number one if
you're the top dog your company your
business is gonna be small number two
you're probably an awesome number two
three and four to a number one that goes
all the way out to the clouds and
doesn't care about the details and you
may be able to make more finances or
whatever you're looking for and be
happier and not have the pressure of
being the number one by Lateran up or
attaching yourself to a number one and
acting your two three four role if your
strength is the finite details you're
upside is limited as the number one you
have two decisions to make one you're
cool with that back to the first
question in this show or to your gonna
latch on to somebody who's going to be
able to elevate and you're eight percent
you're twenty percent you're forty
percent you're two percent of the whole
nut is gonna be greater than 100 percent
of what you're gonna do for yourself
yeah that was sharp
there was a sharpness to that cut in
people with my answer is rusty says I
don't get it Facebook you decide to not
show my book page to people do you think
a lack of success will make me give you
more money rusty I feel you but you know
Facebook is like any other medium in the
world you know like you know Fox channel
network to put your commercial for your
book isn't gonna just do it for free the
Yellow Pages isn't feeling your book and
so they're just gonna put it in there
for free like the Postal Service isn't
like Oh rad your book was creative let's
just ship out flyers for your book for
free this notion that Facebook because
it started as a social network is not
giving free organic reach to people and
what you want my money yes they want
your money because it's one of the most
efficient ways to actually deliver
content to people in the world right you
know like you know cool use the
alternative of free which is what excuse
me use the alternative Facebook and keep
staying free which is what email build
your build your list do your thing
hit that Google you know button boom
MailChimp in the house great awesome
phenomenal show me show me that you can
build that list that's just the way it
is and I think people are ceilings are
hurt
but Facebook the business world the
market doesn't give a crap listen give
asks our co-founder has been said to be
the female version of you do you think
society is ready and would she be
treated the same mm-hmm
listen give India you are picking some
doozies on this weekend edition of the
askgaryvee show this one's got me up
into a higher level as you can tell the
female version of me who I think is
Misha Bainer took my daughter I'm
watching it though I can already see
some differences was just too bad at
first I thought it was like Carbon Copy
but I loved her perfectly the way she is
no I think I think if there was a female
version of me right now she would
struggle more because the truth is
society is flawed and white males get
away with more things than minorities
than females and so I I think the world
is a lot more ready than it was five
years ago or 10 years ago or 15 years
ago indefinitely but uh do I think you
know curse it I mean if we're going
Carbon Copy
you know cursing and that level of ego
and that combativeness of loving the the
competition I think I think would be
less palpable to the masses which is
massively unfortunate and I hope that
they will change at the same token I
think that I don't think people
recognize how much smaller my audience
is by me being me P a lot of people see
the plus side of it I am NOT consumable
to a lot of people there's three to four
little tweaks that I'm fully in control
on to change in a heartbeat that would
make me much bigger I'm just not willing
to do that and I would hope that your
co-founder right yeah I hope that she is
just her all the way through and let the
chips fall where they fall I hope she
doesn't hedge or tries to waver much
like I hope she has no interest in
trying to be just like me if she's
passionate about me in a way that I try
not to be like anybody there's an
incredible it's the most cliche word
right now in the game authenticity but
it is stunning how much truth there you
know it's kind of
stereotypes certain tips are
uncomfortable but like let's get raw
like there's some truth the stereotypes
that's how they become stereotypes
authenticity is a cliched buzzword cuz
there's some truth to it people really
appreciate you rollin the way you rollin
people really appreciate when I meet
them in real life they're like I mean
it's still stunning to me for like oh
damn you know yeah I mean I'm sure an
episode 100 you guys had people coming
up to you and saying oh wow that's how
he is in real life right like people
expect there's a cynicism and that's why
authenticity over indexes and so I
highly recommend so the answer to
questions no and I don't think it's as
accepted as me and I think that's
unfortunate but I just really am I like
to answer to I hope that doesn't change
any of our behavior Daniel asks how do
you think overly edited photos and text
overlays affect the authenticity of
Instagram posts Daniel thank you so much
for a wonderful question just off the
back of authenticity so you must have
been thrilled you know I think it's what
you're trying to accomplish I think that
if you're a photographer trying to catch
the wild like you can't edit and and put
words over it but if you roll like me
we're like a lot of things like you want
to inspire people to think differently
or make them feel something it's really
powerful to put a quote of yours on top
of a photo I really do think it's the
the the strategy the the the will the
interest of the content producer to
really make this judgment call what I
like most of all about this question is
how Instagram really works the ability
to unfollow somebody on Instagram is so
easy and this is a subtle product thing
that I don't think people spend enough
time on people's ability to unfollow
somebody feel so native as you're
scrolling that you know at the end of
the day content is gonna find its
audience if it's good and whether that's
highly edited or super raw or black and
white or booty shots or inspirational
quotes or whatever it is it's going to
find its audience and so I think it's
something that people should not
overthink in in either direction right
it's not a tactic that automatically
makes it pop and it's definitely not a
tactic that's gonna [ __ ] you it just
needs to be right I actually think
you've said it best which is
authenticity has nothing to do with the
action
it has to do with the seed of where this
comes from if you authentically like me
want to put things like kill it a crush
a face to the hair whatever you want to
say on top of a picture that's what's
coming from me that's why I think my
audience finds it attractive in the same
way that if all of a sudden on my
Instagram feed I'm taking sunset shots
of New York City people gonna be like
that's not that's not that's just not
who I am right and that's why I yell at
the rock always trying to edit and [ __ ]
and that's it right like that's it so I
think the questions got the answer in it
which is the word authenticity if it
comes from the heart to have quotes on
top of it and edit it cool if it doesn't
cool cool question of the day what is
the app you are spending most of your
time on right now little market research
of the vaynernation right now for all of
us I highly recommend everybody watches
everybody's responses cuz you'll learn
it's interesting it's just it's it's
sharing the data share your damn data
with me this weekend you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]